the season 4 finale of yellowstone is a
doozy but is it really just a big reset
to the status quo of seasons past and
what's up with casey's visions on
january 2nd 2022 10.4 million viewers
tuned in for the season 4 finale of
taylor sheridan's hugely popular
contemporary western yellowstone despite
its popularity the season has garnered
its share of criticism as it gradually
evolves into a kind of yellowstone
extreme three times the fist fights in
roping three times the beth one-liners
three times the core's light and dodge
ram product placement and three times
the john dutton bemoaning the ever
looming loss of his way of life
i am the opposite of progress
i'm the wall that it bashes against and
i will not be the one who breaks
although the vast majority of season
four plays out more like a succession of
wild west meets modern tv trope
vignettes as opposed to a story tethered
to any overarching narrative the season
4 finale represents a return to the
series roots with episode 10 yellowstone
continues to own this collage-like
approach but uses it to focus on some of
the series more compelling themes in
addition to highlighting its focus on
the tension between progress and old
school conservation grass on the streets
and weeds on the rooftops gives viewers
some much needed reminders about the
psychology that drives the three
remaining dutton children as well as the
larger-than-life father figure whose
approval dictates their every move
season 4 received some criticism for
turning one of the show's most
compelling characters beth dutton into a
bit of a caricature however the series
finale finally gives viewers a glimpse
into the tragedy that drives her while
also reminding them of the shark-like
instincts and two-steps ahead intellect
that served beth so well in previous
seasons after angering her father in
episode 9 beth is so devastated by his
disapproval that she begins packing to
leave the ranch for a moment it looks as
though beth's childish obsession with
earning her father's approval will win
out over the love and stability she has
with rip but jon insists she stay after
losing her mother at a young age beth
became determined to make up the loss to
her father and that tragic mentality has
stayed with her ever since later on beth
walks past her new tween charge carter
and lashes out at him when he tries to
call her mama she projects her own
feelings of loss and guilt onto him and
it's difficult to decide who is sadder
the rejected carter or the broken little
girl speaking from the 35 year old
woman's mouth finally in the midst of
her triumphant manipulation of her long
long-hated adoptive brother beth reminds
both jaime and viewers why she sees him
as a man capable of nothing but betrayal
and cowardice beth has never dealt with
the abortion and sterilization she
underwent at the age of 15 and she'll
forever see her pain as the result of
jaime's actions the finale's repeated
spotlighting of beth's psychological
wounds could mean a return to the
nuanced character that so compelled
audiences in previous seasons
in season 4 episode 4 winning or
learning jaime explains to casey that
he's been fighting for the dutton family
from behind the scenes he's the reason
he reveals why neither casey nor anyone
on the ranch faces any charges for the
vengeance they enact upon the militiamen
in season 3. when casey defends their
actions by saying those were the men
that attacked our father jaime says it
doesn't matter
there is what's just
and there's the law
they are not the same thing
in the season finale john dutton repeats
jamie's mantra in his conversation with
the judge following summer's
over-the-top sentencing
there's a difference between what's
legal
and what's just
this strongly implies it's jon who
teaches jaime the notion in the first
place the difference of course lies in
the two men's understanding of which of
these often contradictory ideas should
ultimately win for jon justice takes
precedence over legality for jaime a
lawyer as opposed to seasoned rancher
the law wins out over anyone's
individual understanding of justice when
the law happens to align with john's
version of what's right he can accept
jaime when the law prohibits john from
effectively or efficiently seeking out
vigilante justice he can't it's a
potentially irreconcilable difference
and one made all the more complicated by
jaime's own actions while jon may have
piles of bodies and gallons of blood on
his hands it is jaime not john who
personally commits two murders in order
to protect himself by way of protecting
the dutton's interests season five
promises to be even worse for the
intelligent but emotionally stunted
jaime after beth visits the inmate who
is hired to kill the duttons and
discovers that jaime was there she seeks
him out and gives him an ultimatum she
believes that even if jaime didn't know
his biological father garrett was behind
the hit the reason he didn't blow his
head off as soon as he found out is that
he also wants the duttons dead death
gives jaime two options one that ends
with him and his biological father in
prison for life or one that ends with
the two dead but as beth's leaving she
offers him a third option jaime can cut
out the middleman and do what he should
have done from the beginning and kill
his own father jaime ultimately kills
garrett by shooting him in the head
after they share a touching moment when
jaime disposes of the body beth follows
him and snaps a pitcher
he should have picked options one or two
when beth returns to the ranch john
demonstrates some semblance of concern
for his adopted son jaime thinking beth
hurt him jaime is a disappointment he
says but he still loves him though
apparently not enough to try to stop
beth from killing him just when it looks
as though jaime might wriggle out from
underneath the dutton's thumb he's
pulled back under of course it's
unlikely he would ever fully betray them
even without beth having this leverage
since jaime's main problem much like
beth is that he lives for the approval
of jon season 4 finale may not be the
explosive cliffhanger of season 3 but it
leaves viewers with plenty of questions
for starters although monica and casey's
relationship only occasionally
punctuates the background of a handful
of the season's episodes casey's vision
on the mountain hints at bigger things
to come for the couple in addition to
having flashbacks to his traumatic time
serving as a navy seal casey interacts
with three different people during his
spiritual journey his deceased brother
who represents all things dutton avery
who represents temptation and infidelity
and an unknown woman or the human
representation of the wolf that sparks
his spiritual inquiry in the first place
casey follows the wolf to a crossroads
though the audience isn't shown what
lies beyond either path
what did you see
i saw the universe
while it's clear that monica thinks the
us refers to her and casey we don't
actually know so much of season 4 hints
at a destruction of the dutton's way of
life that it could just as easily point
to something outside their marriage
audiences are left to wonder what
exactly casey sees after reliving his
time as a soldier and denying the first
two temptations in his vision
casey has repeatedly been posited as the
most redeemable member of the dutton
family so it's likely that whatever
decision he makes on the mountain will
have major consequences for season 5.
jimmy returns to the ranch after finding
both love and himself in his temporary
reassignment at the four sixes ranch in
texas for some reason fired barrel
racers laramie and jimmy's ex-girlfriend
mia are at the bunk house when he
returns with his new fiance emily in
keeping with season 4's fist fights
before storyline style emily and mia
throw down and the latter leaves
distraught it's tempting to see the
fight as yet another macho that's just
how it is here seen but jimmy's
exhaustion with all the drama of the
dutton ranch is key to his decision to
leave it behind jimmy's mentor on the
ranch lloyd struggles to cope with his
young friend's decision
jimmy is leaving behind a life that's
imprisoned lloyd for years and although
he's happy that jimmy has been able to
find happiness it's a reminder to lloyd
that for him that ship has sailed
audiences watch lloyd spiral into a deep
depression in season 4 and the contrast
between his own circumstances and those
of the young ranch hand in whom he once
saw himself only adds to this while
jimmy is able to evolve and see the harm
in attempting to hold on to a way of
life that doesn't really exist lloyd is
not in their opposing understanding of
what the dutton ranch represents jimmy
and lloyd illustrate a major theme in
yellowstone it's the series main
conflict and won the finale drives home
in both its title and john's
conversation with the judge
progression evolution and pragmatism
versus tradition nostalgia and
romanticism
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
yellowstone are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]